tobacco baby with laser eyes lady with
laser eyes Exxon Mobil with laser eyes
these are the most evil businesses in
the world according to 24 year old
capitalist Jake Tran he's a YouTuber
pumping out content that I can only
describe as horror movies but for
business people and that's why of course
I love watching them I mean who wouldn't
like these videos wow this is insanely
evil wow this dude is evil this is
absolutely evil wow this is pure evil
look I know what you're thinking based
on those titles it's hard to choose but
the reason we're here today is because
buried beneath all this talk of evil
businesses and evil people I noticed
Jake Tran has his own weird little evil
scheme going on which I first noticed
watching one of his videos and I can't
remember which one it was it was either
like we're all gonna starve or oh great
we're all gonna die something like that
and what I noticed is that Jake makes
these videos exposing scams but then
often uses the same tactics of the scam
to then pitch you like a sponsor that's
in the same same Lane like for example
he'll tell you that lotteries are
predatory lotteries are predatory they
play on our psychology to suck a strike
of our hard-earned money but then in
that same video he'll sell you a quote
no lose lottery play the no lose Lottery
by pausing the video and clicking the
link below and it's not just that it
seems like he hand-picks these sponsors
for the videos because he also said uh
crypto trading Bots are a scam and often
a way to get people to believe there's a
free money machine back in The Wolf of
Wall Street days you would just shut
penny stocks down people's throats and
take a giant commission a few years back
it might have been selling a stock
trading box or a Forex Trading Bots that
supposedly makes you money while you
sleep but today we have something even
better even more tempting a crypto
trading box now right after learning
that crypto trading Bots are the new
tempting way to get people to give you
their money guess what Jake Tran
advertises and the product itself is
actually legit you can set up your own
custom bots based on your parameters
deploy them to start training
automatically with your money see the
trades come in and would draw all your
money like it's almost breathtaking
isn't it like to see someone denounce a
scam and then in the same breath be like
you know it's not a scam the same thing
now of course in Jake's defense he'd say
that pionex which is the trading bot is
legit because he tried them himself and
he made money I've actually set up
what's called their grid trading bot 11
days ago give it one thousand dollars to
trade with and I'm already up three
percent on it nothing crazy but also
pretty good for just 11 days now the
only problem with this argument is that
Jake says he tried the product but he
messed it up because the what he's
talking about making him three percent
that trading bot actually never traded a
single transaction it says this on his
screen there are zero transactions in
these 11 days he shows meaning that what
he thought was a three percent gain from
a trading bot was likely just Bitcoin
going up by three percent in 11 days but
it gets so much worse our next video I
want to show you is called so it's a
Ponzi scheme but with crypto where he
talks about Africa but then at the end
of the video a appears to make a sales
pitch kind of for a Ponte scheme and the
hottest niche in crypto right now is
flipping nfts where people are making
life-changing money just from getting on
an nft hype early on buying and then
selling soon after for insane amounts of
money and one way to do it is to look at
what crypto whales are buying crypto
whales are influential people who have a
ton of crypto so if you buy an nft
project others tend to follow pushing
the price up the hard part is catching
on to these crypto whale hype trains
early on so you're not left holding the
bag wait a second I want to make sure I
have this right I'm supposed to be able
to make life-changing profits by
catching a hype train early but I have
to make sure I'm not the one left
holding the bag hmm
this sounds a lot like a Ponzi scheme so
new role here on coffee Zilla anyone who
says the hottest niche in crypto right
now is X is evil they're trying to scam
you I mean literally he's promoting
basically what he just announced it's so
insane now to be fair to Jake I don't
think this nft project which was called
meta monks ever launched I think it got
scrapped because they didn't build
enough hype instead less than a month
after it a new video came out from Jake
Tran called the evil business of nfts
and this is where things get even more
bizarre in the weird world of nfts there
is something Sinners they're going on
where criminals are making off with
Millions with what's called a rug pole
okay I'm pretty sure you guys know where
this is going Jake Tran is telling us
how evil and profitable nft rug pulls
are I wonder who the sponsor is so if
people want to get into flipping like
you said to start out are there any
projects that you're looking into right
now that you see potential in yeah and
one thing I want to make clear when
you're new you need to spend a little
more time to really try to understand
that this team is authentic that care
they actually want to build something
because it's really hard to
differentiate who is using these
buzzwords to manipulate you and who
actually has good intentions and wants
to build something for the long run and
so I guess I'll use the project that
we're advising for as the example the
cunning wolf Society I love the
shamelessness the guy you're hearing
from right now by the way is Brett he's
the expert in rug pool supposedly
teaching us how to avoid scams and at
the end of this video he's like yeah you
got to be careful because people will
just say anything to take your money you
never know who to trust oh by the way
buy our nft project the cunning wolves
Society you could not have picked a less
trustworthy names you might as well have
named it the sneaky snakes or rugbull
rabbits I mean who buys into projects
like this like Hey we're the cunning
wolves our defining traits are that
we're devious and predatory now
surprisingly unlike the last time which
didn't really work out for Jake this
time the project that they're supposedly
advising on sold very well over a
million dollars and there's a lot to
this because they ended up using a lot
of the same tactics they describe as red
flags earlier in the video to sell this
project and now that investors are down
80 percent you have to wonder who's left
holding the bag but probably my favorite
part of this whole thing comes right at
the end because like I said earlier
Brett and Jake are trying to push this
idea of like flipping nfts in the form
of this cunning wolf Society but in this
exact video Brett the rug pull expert
tells us that the real money isn't even
in flipping nfts it's in selling to the
people who are flipping nfts I'm making
a lot of money flipping nfts you realize
oh my God the project that I'm buying
these nfts is from are making five
percent of every single transaction it's
like that's where the real money's at
wait wait wait you just told us to flip
your nft and then told us that the real
money isn't in flipping nfts it's in
transaction fees which by the way what
are the transaction fees for the cunning
wolf Society let's just scroll down this
page real quick oh it's five percent
right of course it is isn't it amazing
that they like tell you how it works and
then do the exact thing I mean it's so
Shameless that it almost pisses me off
like Jake Tran actually makes pretty
good content when he's not selling these
get rich quick schemes so I felt like it
needed to be called out and I also feel
like you the audience need to be aware
that just because someone is calling out
scams doesn't instantly make them
trustworthy I feel like a lot of people
just drop their guard and just believe
the next words out of someone's mouth
just because they were the guy who
caught out a scam anyways with all that
said I guess I just want to wrap this
video up by telling you guys about the
new hottest niche in crypto right now